[Music]
all right so one of President Trump's
biggest skeptics during the presidential
primary was conservative radio and
television host Glenn Beck well he now
says he would gladly vote for Trump in
2020 he's here to explain that and weigh
in on the new radical radical extreme
Democratic Socialist Party the anti
semitism scandal Glenn Beck himself also
the author of the upcoming book addicted
to outrage all right good to see up you
are not being brought on this program in
any way we got along great for a while
you were very generous to me at one
point when I needed a radio studio and
you never charged me a penny and you
gave it to people like a year Sean
listen to me we are we are we both
believe that our country is in trouble
we're both men that are very passionate
and there's nothing wrong with that and
no I'm I'm more than happy that you that
you reached out and wanted to talk let
me ask you because it look you've always
been an entertainer and performer in in
so many ways and you know what
everybody's view is very we watched the
Cheetos weather the day after Trump was
elected you know you said you compared
Trump's win to what happened in Germany
in 1933 then you really lost me when you
were hanging out with Samantha bee I
thought that was to me you know a
different point
tell us about well why wasn't you
hanging yeah I wasn't hanging out with
Samantha I wasn't hanging out with
Samantha bee look I think I'm being very
I've been very consistent I was judging
Donald Trump on his record prior to
being president of the United States
that's all you had to judge him on I
said after the election that he is my
president he is all of our presidents
and it is it is in our best interest
that our president succeeds and I want
him to succeed and I said over and over
again I hope that I'm wrong and if I am
I'll be the first to admit it once he
got into office now he's the president
so now I'm not judging him on the past
I'm judging on what he's doing and I
call balls and strikes
and quite honestly Sean early on I said
I never thought he would do that I never
thought he would do that I never thought
he would do that by the time he got to
Israel he was proving me wrong every
step of the way on his policies I was
happy thrilled thrilled to say he's
doing the things he said he would do I
think the problem has been since he got
into office on policies the Democratic
are they I'm sorry the Republican Party
the Republican Party he he is the
greatest misdirection of all time all he
has to do is just tweet something and
the media goes crazy they could have
passed anything and he would have signed
it they didn't I asked what's wrong with
the Republican Party
you know I to me there were way too many
Republicans we learned this over
Obamacare show votes for repeal and
replace 65 of them real votes spineless
visionless feckless nothing nothing same
thing was right you know the only thing
is I might have had an advantage that
you didn't have and like you I I went
out on a limb I told my conservative
audience what I knew about Donald Trump
and if you looked at his record gave
money to Democrats even Hillary Clinton
said nice things about Democrats and I
always knew that that was him playing
the political game he even said it I'm
playing the game in New York so I can
keep my buildings going up electricians
plumbers steel workers working and I'm
still in business because otherwise
you'd be shut out as you look at the
things he's done and the way I look at
it biggest tax cuts conservative
justices fighting like with everything
he's got to get the border wall because
he made the promise Israel is another
getting out of the arena Israel
even the concessions that he got in the
you know standing for abortion saying
standing for abortion saying that he's
against socialism I was there at the
State of the Union and I watched the
Democrats I was sitting right across
from the president in the back and
that's the way that thing should be shot
you should be able to see who's texting
who's laughing who's poking each other
who's mocking Sean I was in the State of
the Union
I thought actions
that's no no I I I never thought I would
say this but I left there thinking I
don't think I would have had the
restraint that Donald Trump had they
were hissing him they were mocking him
the whole time and you didn't see it or
hear it on television because I went
back and watched there is a click now in
the Democratic Party that are as radical
as radical can come well I remember when
when I was told I was a racist for
saying that people were socialist and
the Democratic Party was going to become
anti-semitic and socialists they take
their masks off was my quote because
they that's who they are and they want
to say that well here we are and we are
now at a point where if you'll go ahead
No well let me let me then ask this you
see the new Green Deal no planes no cows
no cars no oil no gas the problem is
it's not just one congresswoman it's a
hundred Democrats at least and and 2020
contenders this is real for them and
then you add to that this this absolute
disgrace they can't even condemn
congresswoman Omar in this case today
and you look at where they stand and
more importantly I think the biggest
abuse of power corruption scandal in
history as it relates to the deep state
those at the top of the FBI not
rank-and-file those in the Justice
Department what they have done and still
not held accountable but I hear they
will be I will just tell you this the
new Green Deal is one of the most
frightening things because if you
actually read the bill forget about the
cars and stuff they don't care they
don't care about the the green thing the
the the second part of that is the
fundamental transformation of our
economic system and that is in there
they are looking to transform our system
when they say the the free market system
doesn't work and it's not going to be
around long
mean it and Democrats the good Democrats
in the center of the country who are not
just playing politics they've got to
wake up to who is the Democratic Party
today these people are serious radicals
they have serious issues with with race
and an anti-semitism they are serious
socialists they are not talking about
Sweden that is a free market with a lot
of welfare on top of it it's not a
socialist country well said
last question gun if you don't mind will
you vote for Trump in 2020 you know Sean
I think when you are looking at a vowed
socialist that want to end the free
market they're not even talking about
abortion now we're talking about third
trimester abortions when you are sitting
here talking about infanticide when you
look at who these people are
there's no way anyone who is standing up
against those guys and actually has a
spine yes now will I say I'm going to
vote for him no and here's why because
anyone I ever say I'm voting for it
loses hiss of death so at least don't
ask if he wants to what time I enjoy
outdoors Joe Lieberman he calls me and
says don't endorse me you're not helping
you're killing me right all right no I
know all right
good to have you back on Fox thanks for
taking the time